Let me go next to Connie from Kenosha, Wisconsin.
Hello.
Hi.
How are you?
I'm great.
I'm doing well.
At least the Dallas veterans mojados.
Yes.
So I am addicted to watching your show and
among everything else surrounding this mess
that we're in.
But I have to wonder, as far as the transition
that has pretty much happened with every other
president elect in the past.
Why is there no path around, um, certain certain
blocks that they're encountering as far as
the head of GSA, you know, making certain
information available to Joe Biden?
I'm really having a hard time understanding
why it's just being why this is being allowed.
So all of these things are different.
So so the important thing is to separate out
a lot of these different things.
So Trump hasn't conceded that's a formality.
It doesn't relate to anything else.
It doesn't change that he won't be president
anymore.
On January 20th at noon, then you've got the
GSA question.
Trump has not signed off and authorized GSA
to sort of start involving the Biden elect
camp in the transition.
And that is an inconvenience.
But as Joe Biden said earlier this week, it
doesn't materially change anything.
Now, Joe Biden is not currently the president,
so he really can't do anything about that.
But the important thing to understand is it
won't change the fact that he will be sworn
in on January 20th.
So it's important to sort of divide these
things up into which ones are just sore loser
ish and which ones really have an impact.
The one that for me is the most concerning
is Joe Biden should be receiving the presidential
daily briefing already.
And he's not as of right now, that doesn't
even read it.
Well, sure.
So at this.
But so to your point, we have a situation
right now where Trump is miserable and hiding
out at the White House and ignoring the PDB.
Biden's not getting it.
If I were a terrorist enclave in some other
country, I would be aware that the U.S. is
very vulnerable right now because they've
got no one reading the PDB.
And you're going to get a president coming
in on January 20th who will not have been
receiving it unless something changes.
So I think it actually puts it puts national
security at risk as well.
And I think that it points out and brings
to light that Donald Trump truly, really does
not have the country's best interests at heart.
Never did.
And he absolutely does not.
You're completely correct about that.
Right, well, cnossen is doing fine.
Everything's OK here, they good boarded up,
but yeah, I'm glad to hear that.
Connie, thank you for calling in today.
Thank you very much.
Love your show.
Thank you.
There is Connie from Kenosha.
What a phone call.
I would even say maybe perfect phone call,
I don't know.